française avec jean bonjour et merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
alors l'opposition continue de dénoncer
un coup de poignard dans le dos après 7
cet accord qui a été signé entre
l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan
qu'en est-il de l'opinion publique
arménienne est elle vraiment opposés ou
cessez-le-feu
je ne crois pas je crois d'abord que le
l'opinion publique arménienne en tout
cas de la diaspora a compris que le
premier glisse machine en a pas eu le
choix qu'il n'a pas signé cet accord de
cessez le feu de gaieté de coeur
il l'a fait parce que la paix d'autres
choix pour préserver le peu qui restait
à préserver militairement après en
arménie évidemment les gens sont
mécontents
je peux comprendre leur sentiment de
trahison parce que il n'avait peut-être
pas le le les informations adéquates
pour comprendre la réalité de la
situation
maintenant il ya une situation qui est
ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui c'est un
accord de cessez le feu
ce n'est pas un traité international qui
règle la question de l'artsakh et donc
il appartient à l'ensemble de la
communauté internationale de mettre en
oeuvre les mesures nécessaires pour
garantir la sécurité des arméniens et de
leur patrimoine en armes ça qu'en est il
du premier ministre nikol pashinian est
il menacé
selon vous après cet accord
écoutez l'armée est une démocratie en
démocratie quand le premier ministre ou
dirigeants quel qu'il soit n'est pas où
ils contestées il est toujours menacée
et évidemment dictature comme en
azerbaïdjan le dirigeant n'est menacé
que par un coup d'état
maintenant
2 n'est pas entré d'informations qui me
font croire que un renversement du
gouvernement patient est à l'ordre du
jour l'exclût pas je n'ai pas
d'information particulière là dessus
mais c'est le jeu de la démocratie et
c'est la grandeur de l'arménie dans
cette situation particulièrement
difficile de ne pas tomber dans
l'autoritarisme et de conserver ces
règles démocratiques
un accord signé sous l'égide de la
russie qui a envoyé des soldats pour
pour garantir la paix dans cette région
du caucase on est ce que cet accord
finalement signe l'échec
des pays européens des pays de
l'alliance de minsk également en tout
cas c'est pas un succès pour ni pour la
france ni pour l'europe ni pour le
groupe de minsk très clairement cet
accord a été conclu sous le haut
patronage de la russie qui ont nommé on
ne connaît pas exactement tous les
détails ne prend que la turquie a eu son
mot à dire
ou en tout cas essayer de le dire est
que le groupe 2000 en tant que tel et la
france et les états unis en particulier
qui en sont avec la russie des co
présidents n'ont pas du tout été associé
à cette décision
donc ce n'est pas un succès pour autant
comme je le disais tout à l'heure ce
n'est qu'un accord de cessez le feu et
le règlement de la paix et d'une paix
que tout le monde souhaite et rennes
doit intervenir et le glaude appartient
au groupe de minsk et en particulier à
la france de prendre les mesures
nécessaires pour s'impliquer et avoir
son influence dans le règlement à long
terme de ce conflit et la france en
particulier
pas seulement parce que évidemment elle
est une elle est longue amitié avec
l'arménie mais aussi parce que son
histoire est de défendre un certain
nombre de principes en particulier celui
du droit à l'autodétermination
elle le fait avec brio en nouvelle
calédonie depuis 30 ans et les accords
de matignon
j'aimerais que la voix de la france
porte aussi haut karabagh ces mêmes
principes
et justement la france qui qui va
apporter de l'aide humanitaire à
l'arménie comment est ce qu'elle est
perçue cette aide
écoutez pour le moment les les arméniens
sont évidemment sous le choc je dirai
davantage que en colère ils ont besoin
qu'on ne les laisse pas mourir
on les a laissé faire la guerre tout
seul contre la triple alliance azéri
villes turques jihadistes
maintenant toute l'aide qu'on pourra
leur apporter y compris et surtout
premier chef humanitaire sera la
bienvenue et sera appréciée dans par les
arméniens d'arménie est évidemment
aujourd'hui peu qu'ils sont qui compte
que par la diaspora qui même si elle
n'est pas toujours très et je parle pour
moi aussi concernés dans le sens où nous
vivons bien au chaud chez nous est
sensible aux gestes notamment
humanitaires effectués par la france en
particulier mais pas seulement merci
beaucoup françois devedjan d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes avocat et militant pour la
reconnaissance de la république du haut
karabagh